CATHERINE LIANG: Hi, everyone,
I'm Catherine Liang, and I'm
with Google TV Marketing.
And I'm here today at the Google
Developer Village at
South by Southwest with CTO
of Pandora Tom Conrad.
And joining us remotely is Mario
Queiroz, VP of Google
TV. Tom, thank you for joining
us, and Mario as well.
TOM CONRAD: Hi, Mario.
MARIO QUEIROZ: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Hey, Tom.
CATHERINE LIANG: So I'd like
to start us off by doing a
little introduction.
Tom, maybe you could start us
off with a brief introduction
to Pandora, just--
TOM CONRAD: Yeah, sure.
CATHERINE LIANG:
--for starters.
TOM CONRAD: Yeah, sure, so I'm
the CTO of Pandora, and I run
the product organization
there.
So that's all of engineering
and product design, and
technical operations, and from
product concepts through
delivering bits to listeners,
it's all kind of my fault.
And I've been with the company
for almost eight years now, so
that goes all the way back
to the beginning,
the creation of Pandora.
And--
just trying to figure this out--
this is my sixth South
by Southwest.
So Pandora is a personalized
radio service.
You come to us on your mobile
phone or on your laptop, or
now on your television, and you
tell us about an artist or
a song that you love.
And our goal is to create just
out of this unending stream of
music that you'll love.
Some old familiar songs you can
sing along with, but also
full of discovery and
personalization.
And that's what we try
to do every day.
CATHERINE LIANG: Fantastic.
And Mario, can you also
give us a brief
introduction to Google TV?
MARIO QUEIROZ: Sure.
Catherine, I'm sure you could
do a great job as well.
I'm Mario Queiroz, and I'm the
VP of Products and the General
Manager of Google TV. I've been
with Google for about
seven years.
And over the past year or so,
I've been heading up the
Google TV operation.
What we're trying to do with
Google TV is basically bring
as many entertainment options
into the living room as we can
through the browser, through
Android applications, and
through Google services
for your TV.
We work with a number of
different TV manufacturers so
that you have an option in what
kind of product you want
to purchase, which is powered
by Google TV. We also work
with lots and lots of developers
bringing great apps
to Google TV.
I'm really excited to be here
with Tom and with Pandora.
I'm a huge fan and a huge user
and listener of Pandora on my
Android phone, on my
Google TV at home.
And I know that I'm one of many,
many fans of Pandora.
So I'm excited to exchange some
ideas with Tom and to
answer some of the questions
from the world.
CATHERINE LIANG:
Awesome, great.
So Tom, tell us what makes
Pandora unique from other
internet radio apps.
What is the Music
Genome Project?
TOM CONRAD: Sure, sure.
Well, I think what sets Pandora
apart from other music
services out there is that we're
the only service that's
focused entirely on you.
We don't see it as our job to
tell you what kind of music
you should be listening to.
It's our job to listen
to your feedback--
your thumbs up, your thumbs
down-- and create this
experience that's entirely
tailored to what you love in
the music universe.
And I think that that's pretty
unique in the music sphere.
A lot of music is sort of about,
this is what's hot,
this is what's emerging, this
is what's cool right now.
And we set all of that aside,
and we just talk about, what
is the music that you love?
And if that's marching band
music, that's great by us.
And what sits underneath all of
this personalization that
we do is this system we call
the Music Genome Project.
And the kind of remarkable thing
about it is, the way
that it works fundamentally
is, we have a team of
professional musicians who come
to the office every day.
They put headphones on, and they
listen to each and every
song that plays on Pandora.
And they analyze those tracks
across hundreds of different
musicological dimensions.
So not just are there guitars?
What kind of guitars?
How are the guitars played?
What role does the guitar play
in the overall composition?
There's 40 different attributes
to describe the
vocal performance.
How gravelly is it?
How breathy is it?
How much falsetto?
All of these different
musicological traits, which
allows us to connect songs
together based on their
fundamental musical fingerprint,
which is where
the whole experience
starts from.
You tell us that you love
a particular song.
We go out in the music universe
and find other things
that are similar, and then take
you on this journey of
music discovery and
entertainment.
CATHERINE LIANG:
That's amazing.
That's exactly I think the
reason why it's caught on so
much and really makes
it unique.
And Mario, can you give us a
brief understanding of what
Google TV--
what features of Google TV
make it unique from other
connected TV platforms?
MARIO QUEIROZ: Sure.
So I think it's important to
think about what's happening
in this world of connected TVs
or the web coming into the
living room.
It used to be 30 years ago that
people had three or four
TV stations.
In this country, for example,
they had access
to the network stations.
TV, with the advent of cable,
went from three or four
stations to 300 or
400 stations.
What happened, and a lot of
people thought, oh, network
television will die and
cable will take over.
That didn't happen.
Today, people still love to
watch American Idol and Modern
Family and Glee, and some of
these great shows on network
television, but they also
love to watch ESPN and
then Fox and so forth.
And what we're seeing 30 years
after the advent of cable,
we're seeing the web coming
into the living room.
And we're going from hundreds
of channels to millions of
channels on TV. And we believe
that the web is not going to
replace traditional television,
whether network or cable.
It's complementary to it.
And so what we believe is really
important and what
we're focused on is, first of
all, enabling a lot of these
new web channels to come to TV.
Web channels come to TV in
ways that people might expect,
which is more video on TV and
lots of that.
For example, through Google TV
you can access more than
80,000 TV episodes and films
through the platform.
But I think beyond video, and
what's wonderful about the web
on your TV in your living room
are things like Pandora.
So not only are you watching
video on your TV, which is
what you traditionally think of
TV as, but you're doing a
lot of other things, too.
Music is one of them.
Most people's TVs are connected
to the best speakers
in the house.
This is why, I think, users have
loved using Pandora on
Google TV. It's because
it goes beyond their
active video watching.
It's really enhancing their
entertainment abilities.
And so, we're focused on
enabling more and more web
content to come to TV through
video and other things.
And also we're very focused
on helping users find the
entertainment that they
want to find.
Because when you go to millions
of channels, the
discovery of content, whether it
be video or other forms of
entertainment through apps, is
really, really important.
CATHERINE LIANG: Great.
So we've talked about Pandora.
We've talked about Google TV.
I'd like to really bring this
together and ask you, Tom,
what excites you
about Google TV?
And what makes the Pandora
experience on Google TV
different compared to your
smartphone, your computer, et
cetera, other products that you
might access Pandora from.
TOM CONRAD: Sure.
Pandora started as a website
way back in 2005.
But from the very beginning, we
understood that if we were
going to be successful in
redefining what radio is, we
had to break free from the
PC and bring the Pandora
experience to all the places
where people traditionally
consume radio.
And of course, a big part of
that story is Pandora for the
mobile phone.
Huge, huge, huge success
on Android.
But about 35% of all radio
listening happens in the home.
And so, for years and years
now, we've been making an
investment in bringing Pandora
into the living room, Blu-ray
players and televisions and
over-the-top boxes.
I think we're on as many as
450 different consumer
electronics devices.
And the challenge there is that
all of these platforms
are a little bit different.
And so you end up with a
different implementation of
Pandora hundreds of times.
And so when Google came to us
shortly before the launch of
the initial Google TV platform,
we were really
excited about this idea that we
could take the investment
that we've made in Android and
leverage that to deliver a
really, really great experience
in the living room.
And thank God we could leverage
that investment,
because I think you gave us
all of about four weeks to
develop for the platform to be
one of your launch partners.
So we sprang into action and
took the Android application
that our users know and love,
and put an entirely new kind
of 10-foot user experience
on top of it.
So you can sit on the couch and
with your remote control
interact with Pandora
very, very simply.
You get big, beautiful album
art on the screen.
And of course, gives your thumbs
up and thumbs down,
change stations, learn
more about the
music that's playing.
It creates a really great kind
of listening environment.
Particularly, I love
it for a party.
You can have it up and going.
Everybody knows what
music is playing.
It spurs all these great
conversations about music and
people grabbing the remote
control, making new stations
to entertain themselves.
I love seeing people come
together around the experience
of Pandora.
And I think the Google TV
application kind of does that
uniquely well.
CATHERINE LIANG: So you touch
upon the fact that it's really
difficult to manage all these
different implementations.
How challenging is that
for your team?
TOM CONRAD: It's a spectacular
challenge.
I'd say one of the big
accomplishments for Pandora is
that we have been able to build
a presence on all of
these different platforms
and devices.
But I certainly dream of a day
where we could take hundreds
of implementations and narrow it
down to just the Google TV
platform, for example,
as a unifying factor.
And the great thing that that
does for our listeners is, it
lets us innovate faster.
It lets us bring new features
to the living room by
impacting just the same code
base that we use for the
Android application, we can
get those onto the 10-foot
experience just immediately.
And it's much, much harder to do
that when you have hundreds
of different locations that all
have to be tweaked to add
new features.
CATHERINE LIANG: Absolutely.
Mario, can you speak to your
strategic vision for Google TV
and what you see that tying into
the music platform as?
MARIO QUEIROZ: OK.
I mentioned a couple
of aspects of
our strategic vision.
One is, we're going to continue
to find ways to make
it easy for developers to
bring their content,
entertainment, their information
to Google TV. So
we've chosen for the Google
TV Android, so that one
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
developers would be if the
developer has an Android,
mobile application, phone or
tablet application, that
they're not starting from
scratch in bringing that
experience to television.
In many cases, many, many
cases, we've seen that a
Google TV app has been developed
very quickly from an
existing Android application.
And we've done that through--
and there are lots of
examples, but I'll just
name a couple.
A lot of applications depend
on touch, of course, on the
phone and on a tablet.
And we've built the platform in
a way that your application
is easily D-pad navigable on
TV, because TVs still don't
have touch screens.
So we've done that.
And a lot of applications on
the phone will work in
portrait mode.
But a TV is not in
It's in landscape mode.
So we've done some things in the
platform so it becomes a
lot easier for developers
to bring the apps.
So for example, the apps are
easily D-pad navigable, they
don't have to require touch,
and that they work in
landscape all the time
on your television.
We'll continue to work
on those things.
Android Market, now the Play
Store, re-branded, is
available on Google TV. It's
the same back end, the same
content that you find on your
tablet and on your phone.
So bringing more content
to television.
That includes the browser,
of course, as well.
And everything we do, we're
not just taking the same
browser maybe that you
might see on your
phone or on your tablet.
We're making it appropriate
for television.
So you can play 10 ADP content
on Chrome on television.
There's a lot of great
high-definition content that
owners of websites want
to play on television.
And we're trying to bring live
TV and video closer together.
An example is the YouTube
app we've built.
A goal is for you to be watching
a TV show, and if you
want to switch to a YouTube
channel, you can switch to a
YouTube channel as easily as
you'd change channels on your
television.
And again, that makes a good
video experience across TV and
web very, very seamless
in both directions.
And I think that by having
an open platform--
I'll go back to what I
mentioned earlier--
we've opened the living room to
forms of entertainment that
you don't think of traditionally
for your
television.
Television is primarily video.
We've opened TV to other
forms of entertainment.
What Tom and the
team at Pandora
has built is wonderful.
There's a cute and very popular
app on Google TV
called Classy Fireplace.
If you want to have a fireplace
in your living room,
you download Classy Fireplace,
and it plays a fun screen
saver type of application.
And I think we're going to see
more and more applications
which are really targeting the
time and use of the television
beyond traditional video.
And again, music is one of
the huge applications.
And Pandora has been
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], and we see
our user really taking advantage
of what Pandora has
brought to Google TV.
CATHERINE LIANG: That's great.
So going back to that decision
point, Tom, to when you
decided to build for the
Google TV platform,
can you tell us--
speaking especially to
developers out there that are
considering building for the
Google TV platform-- how and
why did you decide to be
an early developer?
TOM CONRAD: Sure.
I think for us it's kind of an
imperative to make sure that
Pandora is available in all of
these kind of venues where
people traditionally
consume radio.
So we're doing tons and tons of
work, for example, to bring
Pandora to the car.
We have all kinds of automotive
partners that are
helping us integrate the Pandora
listening experience
into the driving experience.
But really, second only to the
car, the most important venue
for us really is the
living room.
As Mario said, it's the place
where you have the best
speakers in the house.
It's a place where people
come together to
spend time as a family.
And it's a place where
traditionally tons and tons
and tons of radio is consumed.
And so, for us, it's a core
strategic kind of investment
that we make to make sure
that Pandora is
available in the home.
And the really appealing thing
about the Google TV platform
is that, again, we're able to
leverage all of the effort
that goes into building our
Android application.
And we're able to have complete
control over the user
experience on the television.
So we can build this beautiful,
simple, elegant
user experience, and any time we
want to add new features or
enhance it, it's as simple as
submitting a new build to the
now Google Play Store.
And just immediately then,
that's available to our users.
So just being able to leverage
our existing investment in
Android, to have complete
control over the user
experience, to easily be able
to update it through Google
Play, it's kind of a combination
of all those
things that makes it just
a no-brainer for us.
CATHERINE LIANG: So were there
any lessons learned along the
way that you would like to pass
on to other developers?
TOM CONRAD: I think probably
the most important thing is
just to make sure you really
spend time thinking about the
environment of the home, of
the living room, of the
10-foot UI, of the
characteristics of the remote
control and the way that people
want to interact with
the content.
I think the only mistake you can
really make is to not pay
attention to the environment.
Really think about your users,
think about their homes, think
about how they might interact
with your product, and step
away from some of the design
decisions you made when you
were thinking about this tiny
little thing in the
plan of your hand.
Think about this big beautiful
50-inch television and build
from there.
CATHERINE LIANG: That's
great advice.
And Mario, can you speak to some
of the features of the
Google TV platform that
developers should be aware of?
MARIO QUEIROZ: Sure.
I mentioned a couple
of them before.
And let me go over some
of the things.
I made a few notes for myself
so that I can be accurate in
what we're talking about.
So the one key thing is for--
first of all, the developers
have access to go to a fully
capable browser.
Web app developers can bring
their apps to Google TV
through the Chrome browser.
And they, of course, have access
to the application
framework, the Android
application framework.
You have, for example,
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
virtual machine.
It's optimized for mobile
devices available
for Google TV apps.
You have the optimized graphics
powered by our 3D
graphics library.
And 3D graphics based on OpenGL
ES specifications.
We have SQLite structured
data storage.
We have media support for most
common audio, video and still
image formats.
And we have a [INAUDIBLE]
development environment.
So we've tried to bring the
richness of the mobile
platform to TV so that
developers have a lot of
flexibility to bring their
creativity to TV. And we've
seen that creativity come
to life in some really
interesting ways.
We're talking about [INAUDIBLE]
here but sports,
of course, which is tremendously
popular on
television.
So there are a number of
interesting sports apps that
are being built for TV which
take advantage, for example,
of the fact that the
applications, the Android
application on Google TV, have
access to a user's programming
information.
And an application can also
change stations to a
particular channel.
So you can imagine a sports
application that provides,
such as the application
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
which gives you a degree of
excitement of different
sporting events.
And if you see a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] game or an
English [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
game, or a Major League Baseball
game, which is in a
really [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
you could say, oh, this game is
on live right now, and the
app can switch you right
to the station that's
playing that game.
So we're trying to get
developers [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the power of the mobile platform
through the browser
as well as through the Android
application framework.
But we're also bringing some
TV-specific functionality.
And we're at the very
beginning of that.
We're finding some very
interesting things which we'd
expect to bring to market, and
that will give developers even
more access to television
features which enrich their
applications.
CATHERINE LIANG: Fantastic.
And now I'm going to open it
up to the social channels.
And we've collected quite
a few questions.
And, Tom, the first
one goes to you.
So in light of in the news,
a lot of the giant telco
companies have eliminated or
are planning to eliminate
unlimited data plans to curb
usage in overtaxed networks.
Does this cause any concern
for Pandora?
And what is the average
bandwidth for a typical user
in a month of streaming music?
And this comes from
Eric James.
TOM CONRAD: Hi, Eric.
That's a good question.
We get this a lot since this has
become a new story in the
news cycle around this.
But it's been about two years
now since AT&T started putting
caps on data plans and things.
And we've seen no impact at
all to our business, our
growth, people's consumption
of Pandora.
And I think that's because
Pandora is actually a
relatively lightweight
application with respect to
the amount of bandwidth
that it consumes.
A typical user of Pandora in a
month would consume less than
10% of their data plan from
their Pandora listening.
So I think Pandora consumes
less bandwidth
than you might imagine.
And a typical user is in no
danger of impacting their data
cap, if you like, through
their use of Pandora.
CATHERINE LIANG: Excellent.
So they can continue enjoying
all the great music.
TOM CONRAD: That's right.
CATHERINE LIANG: The next one
comes from John Blossom.
He says, question for
the Pandora team.
I love Pandora on Google TV.
I listen to it all the time
through my home entertainment
speakers.
However, one of the ongoing
frustrations I have is that
purchasing tracks that intrigue
me that I hear on
Pandora is not possible via
the Google TV interface.
Moreover, Pandora doesn't yet
offer a purchasing interface
to Google Play Music or social
sharing options for Google+
via Google TV. Any thoughts as
to when we might see better
purchasing integration and
social integration?
TOM CONRAD: Sure.
We don't tend to talk about what
we're going to do next
before we actually do it, but
I can say that it's fun to
watch the Google Play ecosystem
sort of mature and
the great music purchase
products that have been
brought to market over the
course of the last
year or so by Google.
Helping musicians sell music is
a big part of our charter
at Pandora.
I hope to be able to enable
all those kinds
of things in time.
CATHERINE LIANG: Great.
We look forward to that.
And the next question comes
from Tony Bosco.
He says, while playing music in
the background, is there a
way to get thumbs up or thumbs
down without having to go back
to the native app to do that?
TOM CONRAD: That's
a great question.
There's not today, but I'm
excited to work with your
partners at places like LG to
get those thumbs up and thumbs
down buttons right on
the remote controls.
CATHERINE LIANG: Sounds good.
So William McKee asks, having
the option to choose to listen
to an entire album and make a
playlist of a given band that
is pushed to me in the free
version of Spotify.
But does Pandora have any future
plans to implement this
option in their free product?
TOM CONRAD: So we think about
the music world as being kind
of split between radio
style listening.
It's a really, really
simple experience.
You press a button, we
personalize it to your tastes,
it takes no effort at all.
We play old favorites you
can sing along with.
We play new songs that you've
never heard before.
And we really see ourselves
as the future of radio,
redefining what's possible with
radio in this connected
world we live in.
The other mode of music
listening is this kind of this
on-demand thing.
I want to listen to this entire
album right now, or I
want to hear the
song right now.
And I think that's kind of like
the future of the record
store, if you like.
And we're pretty content to
focus on reinventing radio and
to let others sort of
imagine what the
record store might become.
And that's partially because,
when you look at the way
people consume music in this
country, about 80% of all
music listening hours are
in this radio format.
It's a medium that hundreds
of millions of
people enjoy every day.
And so we feel like we have a
lot of work to do there, a lot
of opportunity there.
And we'll let others, like
Google with their great Google
Play Music service, till the
soil in the on-demand world
CATHERINE LIANG: Sounds good.
And now, Mario and Tom, I wanted
to open it up to see if
you guys had any questions
for each other.
I know this is a great
opportunity for you guys as
leads of the respective
organizations
to share some ideas.
So Tom, do you have any
questions for Mario?
TOM CONRAD: Sure.
I love some television.
I watch a lot of TV. And I'm
really interested in this kind
of convergence of the connected
world and the
television.
And one of the great things that
it's enabled, of course,
is that now, in addition to the
shows that are recorded on
my DVR or the shows that happen
to be being broadcast
right now, all these
great movie and
video streaming services.
Of course, Netflix
is one example.
Google has their own
on-demand movie
purchase and rental service.
But one of the tricks as a
consumer is, it's pretty hard
to figure out what
content is where.
I know that I want to
watch Breaking Bad.
But I have to figure out, is
the season that I want to
watch available for streaming on
Netflix, or is it available
for rental, or is it available
for purchase?
And all these different services
on demand and my
cable box, does it actually
happen to be on right now,
live on television?
And I think one of the things
that I'm most excited about
where Google TV is concerned
is, it seems like with
Google's incredible expertise
in search, that you could
solve that problem for me.
My interest is Breaking Bad,
not, I have to figure out what
services it's on.
So can you talk a little bit
about how Google TV is
tackling content discovery
in this windowed,
multi-service world?
MARIO QUEIROZ: Great
question, Tom.
We've taken a pretty big step,
I think, with our last
software updating in
tackling this.
But this is more of a marathon
than a sprint for sure.
We have our TV & Movies app on
Google TV, and we make sure
that we take you through that
app if you haven't seen it.
And Catherine can do it
right there live.
But we're basically
trying to do
exactly what you've described.
TV & Movies is an application
that basically allows you to
go in and, without having to
know what the sources of the
content are, whether it comes
from Netflix or Amazon or
YouTube or HBO GO, or live TV
or wherever that might be,
basically what you've before and
what you've rated in the
future, based on signals from
your Google+ and so forth.
We are providing you
recommendations, if you're
looking for drama or comedy or a
rom-com, whatever that might
be, we're giving you
recommendations of films to watch.
And then we can tell you if
these films are similar to
this particular film that
you've seen before.
Our goal is to help you very
quickly find the content you
want to watch, the movie or the
TV show, and then to say,
oh, now that you know that you
want to watch this, here's a
few different options for
watching this show.
And you click on the different
options for watching.
Well, it's going to be on live
TV on Sunday evening.
And you're like, well, but I
don't really want to wait.
I want to watch it now.
OK, well, you can watch it.
You can rent it now from
YouTube, or you can buy the
show from Amazon.
Or, we know that you have a
Netflix subscription, and it
might be available on Netflix.
So that is our approach,
pretty much what you're
describing is.
Google knows how to aggregate
and index vast amounts of
information from many,
many sources.
And then we're trying to
do that, and rank that
information in a way that's
relevant for you as a user.
And then, we send you to
whatever the destination is
which the content owner would
like for us to send you to.
So we get the information on
what shows are available from
the content owners.
And if Netflix wants us to send
the users, then, to the
Netflix application on Google
TV, that's where they go.
If Amazon wants us to send the
user to their website to view
the movie, then that's
where they go.
But I think it's a
great question.
In this world of millions of
channels, that's exactly what
we have to do, is to help them
find the content, regardless
of the source.
CATHERINE LIANG: And Mario,
do you have any
questions for Tom?
MARIO QUEIROZ: I do.
I think one of the really
important things for all types
of apps coming to TV, but
certainly for music as well.
And so a couple of questions
that you had I think would be
helpful, is to find or to bring
the multiple screen
experience closer together.
Let's say that you launch
Pandora on your Google TV, and
it's running in the background,
you're doing
something else on Google TV.
And one person wanted to
thumbs up or thumbs
down the song.
You should able to do
that on your phone.
So Pandora on your phone should
know that Pandora is
running on Google TV so
that you can thumbs
up and thumbs down.
What ideas or thoughts
do you have for us?
Is it something that would
interest you guys, to work in
a more multi-screen type
of an environment?
TOM CONRAD: Yeah, absolutely.
Just as a baseline, to remind
everybody, you have a Pandora
account, and that's a universal
account across all
of the places that you
enjoy Pandora.
And so, the stations that
you're creating and
personalizing on the web or on
your phone are available when
you're connected in your car
or available on your
television.
So we do have this kind of
universal experience today.
But what Mario is getting at,
I think, is really the
exciting potential evolution of
that, which is, how can we
use the phone in your pocket
to control the television?
How can we bring people
together to let them
collaborate around the
listening experience?
We've got a bunch of exciting
ideas in that area, and it's
another example where
the Google TV
platform is so powerful.
When we have complete control
from our development
environment of both the
television and the phone,
there's suddenly so many things
that we can easily do,
make enhancements to both, to
allow them to cooperate.
It's so much harder when you're
talking about this kind
of more heterogeneous world with
hundreds of differences
and limitations and things.
So I'd love to see Pandora kind
of innovate around this
multi-screen listening
experience.
And Google TV would be a really
great place to begin
those experiments.
MARIO QUEIROZ: We're looking
forward to hearing from you
and your team and from other
developers on [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
for us and how we should
be doing that.
CATHERINE LIANG: Do you guys
have any last comments before
we wrap up?
Tom?
TOM CONRAD: No, this is great.
It's a shame you can't all
be here in Austin.
The sun is finally coming out.
And Google's taken over
an entire block.
It's pretty exciting.
CATHERINE LIANG: And Mario?
MARIO QUEIROZ: Well, I just want
to thank Tom again for
joining us.
Like I said at the beginning,
I love Pandora and I think a
lot of our Google TV
users love Pandora.
And I know that our OEM, LG,
Sony, Samsung are really
excited about working
with you guys.
TOM CONRAD: Great.
CATHERINE LIANG: Thank you both
for taking the time to
join us this morning.
And thank you all for watching
and listening in.
Signing off from South
by Southwest
MARIO QUEIROZ: Bye-bye.
TOM CONRAD: Bye, everybody.